okay so we're continuing our
conversation about the possible future
or futures
of the republican party in this time
when they've stopped even pretending to
be about issues and policy
and as we talked about earlier in the
show they've become the party of
performative outrage what about
that new party that donald trump might
start
are there a lot of republicans who would
abandon the republican party and follow
trump
or would it be an exercise in futility
well we have
a poll about this and the numbers
are a disaster for the republican party
64 percent of registered republicans
nearly two-thirds of registered
republicans
said as of the last few days of january
that they would leave the republican
party
and join a new party led by donald trump
if he were to do that now very
interestingly
28 percent of independence and 15
of democrats also said they would likely
join a third party led by donald trump
um so what yeah
the first takeaway is how on earth
do 15 percent of democrats end up liking
the idea
of following donald trump to a kooky
third party that's not a great sign for
democrats
it implies that a significant portion of
democratic support is what we would call
soft support and we probably many of us
inferred that uh
some some years ago but it is yet
another indication that at least
some support of uh of democrats for
their own party
is quite weak and they would abandon
ship but 15
of democrats is nothing compared to 64
percent of republicans
the bigger problem for republicans is
now that we are
several weeks post donald trump
it is still for now the party of trump
uh and of course if donald trump
launches his own party it would almost
ensure disaster for republicans at least
for one election cycle but probably for
more
and i love the idea and i hope it
happens i mean we you know we talk about
a third-party party spoiler effect
when a third-party candidate has a min
a uh one percent two percent in some key
states
a third-party spoiler like we have never
seen
before would be possible with 64
of the republican party being willing to
leave
the republicans and follow donald trump
now let's be
very very honest with ourselves there's
no doubt
that some of the 64 percent in the poll
who said i would leave the party and
follow trump
they wouldn't actually
they they baby like the idea of it right
now or they're saying that that's what
they would do
in order to you know alarm the
republican party and the republican
party should be very alarmed
but i don't think 64 of the republican
party would actually abandon it and
follow donald trump but
it could be 50 it could be 45 it could
be 58
any of those numbers i mean even 25
abandoning
would uh destroy the republican party
for at least one election cycle if not
more um
if you're wondering by the way why
we've seen the republican elected
officials
mostly again start kissing trump's ass
after the january sixth insurrection and
since he left it's because of these
numbers
and you know marjorie taylor greene and
these people
are completely out of their mind they're
radicals they're terrible for the
country but when they
say this is still the party of trump
when they say trump still has our
support
he still has the support of the party
they're right they're absolutely and
completely right and that is what these
numbers
show us so i hope donald trump does do
this
um i it would be the exact cover that
democrats could use
to just have republicans too busy to
obstruct joe biden's policy ideas it
would be absolutely delightful
i fully support donald trump starting
another party
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently checked out the
book podcast marketing strategy by
daniel rolls and kieran rogers
and so useful so particularly applicable
to what i'm doing
really recommend it blinkist has books
on politics philosophy science they have
27 different non-fiction categories and
a subscription is only about eight bucks
a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video